hey welcome back to the channel this is
the samuel and amanda show
hey guys nice to be back again this week
i love
the setting you've done a great job i
mean we've changed
everything you look great on camera the
the background is awesome
amanda's basically a man who's
responsible for always getting the light
right you know what she always does
she always sets it so that she looks
great kind of really pasty
no no actually what happens is i always
look fine in the shot and then samuel
steps in and then suddenly to balance
this out it makes me look really really
dark all of a sudden what
do you mean is that just because i'm
there was that because the camera
changes
no because you're light well you're
white and i'm flexible it just reflects
off of you
yeah but i think we complement each
other well actually but anyway um
so today we're going to be talking a
little bit about fashion
and clothes and the importance
of fashion and clothes in business
because it's something that
i get pulled up on all the time and
ironically
amanda is a fashion designer no
okay no samuel says something sometimes
i mean it's a great compliment
i'm not a fashion designer you want to
be a professional professional
let me ask you a question did you
answering yes or no did you or did you
not have a website
as a fashion designer i did
yeah wait wait so when we wait it was a
fashion
stylist okay sorry amanda is a
fashion stylist self-appointed by the
way
it's not like it was never a job or
anything but you just kind of used it as
a hobby right yeah
you helped your friends and you had your
website yeah
you know beautiful website in fact
amanda hasn't changed a bit since we got
married you even wore after having
three kids you wore the dress
that you were wearing when we very first
match i know i've still got it and i
think i'm gonna keep it
like forever and it fits i it's crazy
and again that's fashion as well
fashion so fashion um and business
and you know obviously you can tell by
looking
i take a lot of pride in my fashion you
know i wear
wonderful t-shirts every single day the
same cloth i pretty much wear the same
clothes
yeah you're quite predictable in your
clothing which we're getting onto yes
but right now what we've been up to this
week this week's been fun
um i'm actually and i haven't talked to
you yet about it but we want to
one of our tenants has moved out of one
of our properties in wales and i'm
thinking you've said not thinking well
you've said that you want to have it as
like an essay yes
service accommodation when you told me
that they were leaving i was rejoicing
because i was thinking
we're losing so much money on the house
i know it's in a beautiful location that
was the house
that when i went to snowden do you
remember when i went i went to snowden i
didn't stay in
ah yeah did you have you told the story
before no all right should i tell the
story yeah
it's a good story i went to snowden
mandy always books my hotels
did did you mess up on that day did you
not bought me a hotel no i think
i don't know what happened but no no
you'd said honor it's fine don't worry
about booking yeah i don't like to book
hotels
until the day off because my plans
continually change
so if if i'm like booking up if i'm
going away somewhere in like three or
four days
and amanda's like do you want to book
your hotel i'm always like yeah
wait until the day of when i'm actually
driving
and we i know i'm gonna go there yeah
however that time backfired on me
because i was driving to snowden
and i said to amanda bought me a hotel
she ran me she goes samuel
i cannot find your hotel yeah i'm like i
might just find
something it doesn't have to be fancy
just finding me a travel large
she goes i'll have a try you remember 20
minutes later and what happened
there was no hotels nothing nope within
how far
could you put me on 20 minutes down the
road no no within like half an hour of
the house there wasn't any hotels
available
nothing yeah of the house i was climbing
snowdon so i was just saying booked me
somewhere near snowdon
there was no house and there's this oh
right yes there wasn't a house
then i said we own a house yeah
it's snowdonia area yeah she goes
there's no tenants in there
so you can go and crash there yeah she
says there's no sleeping blankets
it's gonna be really rubbish night but
i'm like there's like five of us
three bit house so we just turn up at
one of my one of my houses manny goes
with the keysight code
when we get there there's actually a
tenant in
the house we've got the wrong day
there's been some mix-up right
and knock the door the tenants opened
the door i'm like
are they squatters yeah you were shocked
amanda told me there was no one here are
they squatters
they're like hi i'm like give me a
moment a ring amanda vermin it's like
midnight
mandy's like oh yeah actually i think
those mix up there are there whatever
so i said to them i need to crash here
do you mind they were like no come on in
you're a great landlord
i said i've got another four friends
with me um
we ended up sleeping on the floor
right now on the floor
so the moral of the story is the fact
that there's no hotels around that area
means we need a hotel in the area that
house the tenants have now finally moved
out
so we need to rent do that as an airbnb
anyway so that's what
we've been up to yes yeah that's what
i've been up to i've been dealing with
i've been driving around like crazy
haven't i you've been
oh here there and everywhere my back is
aching for the driving i need another
massage
you had your first massage i appreciate
it first massage it was so nice like i
really that's the only thing i miss when
i'm pregnant
and i know that they say you can have a
massage when you're pregnant
i just don't trust it i just don't want
to risk it just in case because
they say like they might do something on
your back that then might affect the
baby so i just never take that chance
that
first massage it was like an hour long
really like full body oh it was amazing
so
i love that and i've started working out
this week that's another thing so i
started exercising again
she's saying to me this is what she's
saying i'm not sure about my workouts
she's
literally said she goes well that's what
i'm doing i'm not losing any weight i
said
sweetie it's your second workout
since no come on i think people can
relate to this okay when you've eaten
really really well for one day exercises
and done everything
you feel like when you step on the
scales it's going to reflect that
immediately yeah
but yeah so i need to be patient you
were like trust me i've put a little bit
of weight back on
annoyingly it's depressing looking at
pictures from like six eight months ago
because now i'm bigger than i was
locked down has been so long that when
lockdown happened i got in shape now
i've got out of shape again
now i'm gonna get back in shape all
before lock man lifts properly
that's a long lockdown it is depressing
when you um
it's just it's the hardest part of my
life
is you're waiting it is yeah
eating food right you know like
it's the hot you know when you do the
wheel you know the wheel and it's like
you've got finances church recreation
friends family relationships
spirituality
and you have to do the wheel and it
shows you how balanced you are in your
life yeah if you're really rich
but you've got a terrible marriage
that's not great
you know the bad one for me is always
food um i think it's just because i'm on
the road so much
that's not you like convenience it is an
excuse but it's convenience isn't it
i work out every single day i spend like
an hour every day working out
but i know why i'm overweight it's
because
i just eat whatever i want
which sometimes is a lot and bad foods
and stuff like that
so i am struggling for trying
and you know it's one of those things
whereby
i don't know i guess you you you
everyone's gonna have certain things
that they struggle with more than others
i know guys that are really ripped
but they struggle with their finances
and it's just it's just one of those
things so
yeah at least you're working on it
working working on it working on it and
now we're doing it together
we are because i've joined you again
fashion
by the way we didn't have any questions
from the last podcast we had loads of
nice comments
everyone's nice comments thanks for
those comments but like no questions
so any questions that you've got about
money
marriage life business
personally about me and amanda drop them
below and we will do our very best
answer next week we're quite a
transparent couple
yes we've had ups we've had downs mostly
ups
um but yeah really open so just ask us
anything
so fashion i want to talk with you
amanda
yeah about fashion because
in business like sometimes you hear
stories like some of the other dragons
there yeah
if someone walks in on the dragon's den
and they're not wearing a suit
the dragons will be like you look like a
scruff and they won't do business with
them
so there's an argument to say that your
appearance is really important what you
wear
is really important you are a
fashion what was it again oh my goodness
fashion stylist it's not like an
official thing by the way
it's just you know it's like a very
official thing
do you remember remember when you came
on um
the eviction and and when you go on the
eviction on the show
they put your name and then they put
your occupation and i'm sure they said
you were
an interior designer which again is one
of those things that you have oh my gosh
i did a course in it yes
and i'm interested and you know yeah but
but they said
they put into it because i don't know
um but anyway so you are um a
fashion no okay let's just say i'm
fashionable you love fashion i'm yeah
yeah i do and i'm conscious of what i
wear and i'm bothered about what i wear
whereas you
aren't yeah so
talk to me about why do you think it's
important to be
fashionable and then i'll talk about why
i think
fashion is overrated not to say
appearance isn't important of course
which is why it's potentially overrated
and then we can let the audience make up
their minds i know everyone's gonna
agree with you
yeah because i think most people do um
think that it's important but i think
dressing well
is very important because of first
impressions
for example so when you meet someone for
the first time yeah the first thing that
they see is what you're wearing
yeah so i think like if you do
i think if you're unkempt then it kind
of says a little bit about you and that
you probably you're a bit careless maybe
not that clean depending on what you're
wearing yeah no
no no no no no there's a big difference
between not being fashionable and
wearing
designers and not being hygienic okay
they are two different things okay but
you don't have to wear designer clothes
yeah to to you know to look um
like what what i wear right i'll wear
this everyday i just wear like really
basic tops yeah i'm very clean i shower
twice a day
it's got nothing to do with hygiene here
like okay it's not
messy it's not unkept my the only thing
that's going to catch about right now is
my hair and
rate my hair because i gave them a
haircut last week and he's been he put
on his instagram
he put on his instagram he rated me a 5
out of 10 for his haircut
i personally think for someone who's not
a hairdresser right i think i've done
all right and he's the one that kept
saying
no i want it short i want it short so i
ended
yeah but anyway i just think that it's
important with hydra so i don't think
you have to wear designer things i mean
i don't
i don't wear design things all the time
um but and i don't even dress up like
all fancy all the time
but i do think that you kind of have to
take pride in your appearance
yes all the time where's you
like if you can't be bothered you just
can't be bothered if i'm leaving the
house
then you kind of have to look a bit you
know presentable yeah
i don't disagree with you i think
appearance is important i guess what i
think there is i think that
whereas i think it's um fashion is
overrated
because i just think it's crazy that if
this
top the exact same top
had a little gucci symbol here
yeah it would be 100 times the price
potentially that's ridiculous
yeah okay so i don't know i think i do
think sometimes with certain pieces of
clothing it's like
what's the point but i think there is
some things that you can actually
buy and invest in that will last you a
long long time
no no no no no no no
don't say that that is what i do yeah
yeah so samuel
he found that he loved these perlers
right the comfy simple
so he was like he's just like oh just
buy me like
10 20 of us so then he just buy he just
wears the same thing
it looks like he's just wearing the same
top every day but he's not he like has
literally if you open the wardrobe it's
like just all of these
yeah all that belts if i find a belt
that fits me a nice bow
no 12 pound bow not too expensive just
don't spell but can you give me 10.
yeah something that frustrates me
actually with samuel and i've
told you this before if he goes anywhere
he always loses stuff or
leave things behind so i'll buy him
something nice
might be designed or might just be just
something that cost a bit more than
some achieve all right he had a pair of
yeezy trainers
he went to new york yeah did you you
went to your ff challenging and he left
them in a hotel room
and he's just something a pair of yeezys
what else have you done
like anything like that ralph lauren
jumpers anything also expensive um
it's all right yeah expense expensive
and it's so
you get your toiletry bag and if i've
got like a hundred pound
sprays like it's just such a waste
i'll put my toiletry stuff in the toilet
in the hotel toilet i'm gonna go from
here
and it's so easy to forget right yeah so
so it's so it's funny so the fact
that because if i have something that
costs like i don't know
something that's design or anything like
something that just costs a bit of money
i'll always be like all right i need to
pack this away where is like
no matter how much cost you'll look at
something i'll buy you something and you
won't lose but oh thanks
and so i don't think like you're even
aware no i'm not
so he's not like even aware or bothered
about oh
is this fashionable is it not as long as
it feels good
like oh my gosh within the day when we
went into town
he was gonna go paragliding and he
needed some like
boots that supported his ankle so we
went into sports direct
and then samuel was like gosh
you know if it wasn't for you i'd just
be wearing these shoes all the time
and there were sketches but not like
sketches would trade with laces there
were sketches that you just slip like
fling souls that you just slip your foot
into
because again he likes convenience he
doesn't like laces on his trainers on
his shoes
so i was like sketches i mean nothing
i don't even know what sketches are i
just thought they were nice but you see
i just think there's things that are
fashionable that are like
in i don't keep up with that to me if
it's
comfy if it looks nice yeah you're more
comfort over anything but
i just think no you can't wear sketches
it is it is really interesting how
different we are
in that area yeah we're very different
but the flip side to me losing stuff
is sometimes it comes it pays off to
your advantage because i'm in love with
something
like if i'm in love with like my yellow
hoodie yeah
they used it all the time and a man
needs to be a bit like yeah he had a
yellow hoodie and a yellow
curt yeah i just wear it all the time
nice
bright yellow happy easy and coming
comfy easy loved it
lost it and now i don't have a yellow
hoodie anymore
so the yellow hood hoodie is no more
no more so yeah so i i think also here
let me let me just argue as well rather
than on me against
fashion anything overrated i think
what's why
more important than the question is who
you are
oh yeah definitely and i think if you
are a confident
person and if you are if you are a good
communicator
yeah if you are well spoken if you are
kind a kind person
if you add value in business if you
look at focus on your staff and your
customers and
like as long as you don't look bad as
long as you look respectable like this
isn't bad
no it's not bad it's respectable but
it's so quick and easy
i would rather have 10 of these no one
cares
like you will say oh i don't want to
wear that dress because i wore that
three months ago
and i'm going to the same event and
there was some of the same people i'm
like
who gives a monkey
and anyone that does care anyone that's
going she wore that dressing i'm scared
could she not afford
another dress like who cares
i get people all the time
cussing me because of my weight my
appearance my
clothes trolls online and it's like if
they're that sad
i don't care what they think i care what
you think
i care what my family think of my
customers my business but like i just
want to live a simple life
i want to just get up i don't have to
spend time
thinking about what to wear i want to be
thinking about
how i'm going to be effective that day
so any brand and in fact if you look at
some of the richest people in the world
this isn't just me i don't know how
freaking rich in the world
but if you look at like people like mark
zuckerberg and bill gates and even
people like simon cowell
and they also wear the same clothes
outfit they wear the same clothes every
day and guess what
no one cares that's not that's what do
you have to say
yeah no i i totally get what you mean
and i think
like for me i don't dress for anyone and
i don't really care what anyone thinks
it's more about just
me and satisfying myself yeah that's
true i think that's the important thing
but yeah so just do you i guess if
you're happy
and you do dress me like you do put my
clothes up for me
yeah i know you're guided by me going i
yeah i know but the thing is
i did some shopping for samuel we
haven't even two weeks ago
two weeks ago maybe even a bit more yeah
he's got new shoes
new tops some shorts like chino shorts
and stuff
yeah he hasn't even opened the package
and i've been like oh you need to try it
on you try on
and he's not even like no interesting so
like
i'm glad that you bought them for me i'm
grateful and if i wake up and they're
there i'll wear them
no no but even now right he used to be
used to be really good because you just
wear whatever put out sometimes he's
like i don't want to wear that top i'm a
rebellious yeah
i always got a mind
oh my goodness so yes yeah i think as
well
um when when you are slimmer i know i'm
not
really flat or anything but i am a
little bit you can't
you can't experiment as much right you
can't be quite as so sometimes they'll
be like a shirt but if it doesn't
quite fit or if i think it's going to
lift up and show my stomach
you know what i just rather just wear my
this is safe i'm safe wearing this like
so it's just like i don't have to think
i don't have to mess around or you know
so i think but when lockdown finishes
well i've lost a bit of weight again i'm
back in shape we can do like a shopping
dinner
we'll do shopping day we'll vlog it yeah
we'll vlog it
we'll vlog it a shopping day do a show
and tell
and cause because again the reason i'm
trying to be in shape
it's not for anybody else it's for me
because it's more a health thing
like i i do booper you know we do
it every year and and and they'll be
like man it isn't
healthy so the weight thing i think is
more for me
and for my family for my kids to have
energy um
clothes thing i'm also bothered about
but
there we are do you agree with me or do
you agree with amanda yeah he's right
um we haven't got any questions from
last week so normally at this point we
take questions
which is really open now so we're just
going to sit in silence for five minutes
um well you've got questions for next
week
okay so put some questions for next week
um
and i don't know what we're gonna be
talking about next week but we'll always
keep it fresh
money marriage life whatever you want to
hear about whatever you want to talk
about let us know in the comments and we
will cater
to your interests for your entertainment
and education
final words of wisdom uh
okay um simply treat others as you'd
like to be treated i see people like
writing mean comments all the time
yeah online especially and i just think
it's so ridiculous
if the person was in front of you you'd
never say those things
so why do you have the balls to say it
over
over the computer um so yeah just think
before you type
and just be nice and spread love and
kindness everywhere you go
that's so true spread love and kindness
everywhere you go treat everybody as
family because ultimately we are
all we're all one and we're all one race
which is the human race
um but yeah so thanks so much for
watching and we look forward to seeing
you guys
next time peace out
you